la nature et le calme c'est ce qui a
séduit philippe et sa femme ils viennent
ici depuis cinq ans il ya beaucoup de
ballades très bien fléché on peut se
promener on peut enfin voilà quoi girija
devi route il ya pas trop de monde sur
les routes enfin voila c'est pour se
promener c'est super le camping est
presque complet et il devrait le rester
pendant tout le mois d'août une belle
saison en perspective pour les
propriétaires même si elle a démarré
plus tard que d'habitude
l'an dernier on a peut-être plus de
monde au mois de juillet cette année les
touristes ont eu du mal de venir on a on
a moins de nuitées au mois de juillet
que l'an dernier mais sans que la saison
est de plus en plus courte
elle commence plus tard puis on finit
toujours autour du 15 du 15 septembre de
15 août pardon
dans cet autre camping les gérants
peuvent compter sur une clientèle fidèle
qui revient chaque année
ça fait bien la 21e année dans le
camping du jura et auparavant je prenais
des locatifs à baume les messieurs n'ont
ils s'appelaient quasiment 1 pén 5 à 25
30 ans que nous voulons dans le jura
tout le temps dans le jura une région
qui est magnifique réputé pour ses lacs
et autres donc on en profitait
ici aussi le mois de juillet a été
plutôt calme notamment à cause du report
des examens mais le département continue
d'attirer de nouveaux touristes grâce à
des opérations de communication
on va dans les salons et puis surtout le
bouche à oreille nous on est sur la
traversée entre le nord et le sud et
donc les passages ils deviennent des
séjours voilà parce qu' on essaye de
promouvoir notre département donc on
parle on parle de toutes les richesses
du jura dont automatiquement il ya des
retombées
si la météo se maintient ou tu devrais
faire oublier le début de saison
difficile le jura pourrait même
enregistrer une légère hausse de
fréquentation